-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Questlove, Tariq,
Kirk, Mark, and Dave
from The Roots.
And we're at Luna Park
in Coney Island, Brooklyn.
People have been coming here
for over 100 years to have fun,
go on rides, play games,
and be entertained.
There's an energy to this place,
a spirit, a magic.
And with that in mind,
I invited Justin Willman
to show us a new trick.
I think he's right this way.
Let's check it out.
♪♪
-What's up?
-What's up, bud? How you doing?
-Good to see you. I'm good.
It's great to see you.
Hi, guys.
-Hey, what's up?
-What's up, man?
-Welcome to Coney Island.
-Wow.
-Thanks.
-Since we're in
Coney Island, Brooklyn,
I thought we'd play
a game tonight.
-Okay.
-Okay? Now, this is a game
that my dad used to play with me
when I was a kid.
My dad's not a magician.
My dad was an airline pilot
for TWA back in the day.
Remember TWA?
-Of course.
-Quality airline.
So, he'd come home from a trip,
and we'd have
a family game night.
And we'd always play
this one game that he invented
called Right on the Money.
-Okay.
-Alright?
Here's how it went down.
He took a handful of coins
out of his pocket.
He poured them into
this little cigar humidor box
so I couldn't count them.
On the wall,
he had a map of the U.S.,
and all the 50 states
had a different point value.
You follow?
-Yeah.
-He'd give me some darts.
I'd throw the darts at the map
till I hit four states.
I'd total up the score of the
states with an old calculator,
and if my score equaled the
amount of change in the box --
150 points, $1.50 in the box --
it meant I'd won.
I was right on the money.
And as a prize,
my dad would take me on a trip
anywhere in the world
I wanted to go.
-Wow.
-And over the years, my dad and
I went on zero trips together.
[ Laughter ]
-I was gonna say.
-'Cause this game sucked.
And I forgot about the game
until my son Jackson's 2nd
birthday earlier this year.
My dad, in a very sweet gesture,
gifted us his cigar humidor
with the darts
and the old calculator.
Even made a brand-new map
of the U.S.
And I'd be honored, Jimmy,
if you would play
the role of my son.
-[ Laughs ]
-Aww.
-Perfect.
-They grow up so fast.
This is perfect. Okay. Now,
and this is what's exciting.
So, NBC's arranged
a great prize.
If you win, Jimmy,
if you're right on the money,
everyone in The Roots
gets a pair
of round-trip,
first-class tickets
anywhere in the world on TWA.
-Ah, on TW--
-Right? Right?
[ Laughter, groaning ]
-Come on, come on.
Kirk, where would we go?
Where should we go?
-Um, Costa Rica?
-Costa Rica.
Let's win a trip
to Costa Rica, Jimmy.
-Let's go. Let's win
a trip to Costa Rica.
-Come on. Big, big money.
-Costa Rica. No pressure.
I'm going to get
the money out, here.
-Okay.
-I'll let you just listen to it.
[ Coins jingling ]
-Yeah.
-You hear that?
-I can't guess how much that is.
-Here we go.
Coins go in the box.
-Coins go in the box.
-Jimmy, stand on
your throwing mark.
I'll give you the darts
one at a time.
-Okay.
-Godspeed.
For a trip to Costa Rica.
-You want me to equal
what's in the box.
-That's exactly right.
No Whammies.
-Alright.
-Mississippi.
-Alright. Mississippi. Yeah.
-Yeah. Good answer.
-Dart number two.
That's 20.
So it's more than
20 cents in there.
-South Dakota, Jimmy.
-Okay, I see what you're saying.
-Okay, okay.
-Water.
-So close.
Tried to pull a Babe Ruth.
-We're in the water.
We're in the water.
Well, so, which --
I'll give you a freebie here.
-Thank you.
-Which state
do you want it to be?
Do you want it to be Wisconsin?
Michigan?
-Wisconsin. Let's go Wisconsin.
-Wisconsin. That's what
you were aiming for.
-That's what I was aiming for.
-Wisconsin. Wisconsin.
We got Wisconsin
and Mississippi. Alright.
Two down, two to go.
-Yeah. You want
South Dakota, Tariq?
-Yeah, yeah, South Dakota.
-There you go.
-Okay, cool.
-Missouri.
-We got Missouri.
That's my home state.
24 points.
-Hey.
-Last one.
-I knew that.
-Why don't you throw this one
with your eyes shut?
Don't -- And I'll stand
a little further away.
Yeah, don't make me regret this.
-I'm not gonna
throw it backwards.
-Wow. Lots of faith they have.
-You never know.
-Alright, eyes closed,
here we go.
-Alright.
-Hey.
-Nice.
-Not bad?
-Yeah. No one's screaming.
It's good. You can open your --
So, Oregon. Alright.
Wisconsin, Missouri,
Mississippi.
-Yes.
-Let's do the math. Old-school.
-Yeah, old-school calculator.
-We got Wisconsin for 30 points.
-Come on.
Let's go to Costa Rica.
-Plus, we got Missouri
for 24 points.
-That's correct.
-That takes to us 54.
-Okay.
-We got Mississippi
for 20 points.
Takes us to 74.
And we got Oregon for 33.
Which takes us to --
-107.
-Yeah, 107.
-107?
-Yeah, I was trying to help.
Yeah, okay, 107.
-107, alright, good.
-What's happened to us
as a culture?
107, which means
if there's $1.07 in that box,
we're going to Costa Rica on an
airline that no longer exists,
which is magic to me.
You feeling good?
-Yes.
-Confidence?
-Justin, I love this.
-Step on over here, Jimmy.
Scoop up all the coins.
I don't want to touch them.
-Okay.
-Scoop them all up in your hand.
And you can stand right here
next to me.
-Oh, I don't know if we're going
to Costa Rica, guys.
-This is the drama.
You got this. Alright.
So, build the excitement.
Go big coins first.
-Big coin-- Alright.
-Going for $1.07.
-Alright, so that's a quarter.
50 cents.
-50 cents.
-75 cents.
-75.
-A dollar.
-$1.
-$1.05.
-Yep.
-$1.07.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Nailed it!
-We're going to Costa Rica.
Yeah!
-On TWA.
-There's more? There's more.
-Oh, man.
-Alright, $1.08.
-Yeah.
-$1.18.
-Yeah. Welcome to my childhood.
This game sucks.
-Yeah.
-This game sucks.
-It's a dark game.
-I would be so upset
at this point.
This is where, normally, my dad
would try to calm me down
and be like, "Buddy,
Costa Rica's overrated.
You don't need
to go to Costa Rica."
But I would be upset.
-Yeah.
-I don't want my son to feel
the way you feel right now.
-Thank you.
-So that's why I've been
giving it a magic makeover
to make losing fun.
So here's my pitch. How many --
Let's see. You hit four states,
four states --
Oregon, Wisconsin,
Missouri, Mississippi.
Four states. How many quarters
were there in the mix?
-There were four.
-Four quarters, four states.
-That's correct.
-Pull out those quarters.
Hold those quarters.
So, Jimmy, in 1999,
the U.S. Treasury issued
commemorative state quarters
where they put a different
one of the 50 states
on the back of each quarter,
and you could
collect them all, right?
-Oh...
-So, I collected them all.
I mean, just for kicks...
-This is --
-[ Laughs ]
-...Jimmy, why don't you tell us
what states are on the back
of those quarters?
-Mississippi.
-Wow.
-Oh!
-Mississippi.
-Oregon.
-Wow.
-Okay!
-Oregon.
-Wisconsin.
-What?!
-Missouri.
-No way.
-Right on the Money!
-Come on!
-How in the world?
How? How?
-Sorry about Costa Rica, but --
-My eyes were -- Yeah, sorry.
-But, Jimmy, it's cool.
Costa Rica's overrated.
You're good.
Don't worry about it.
-Whoa!
-Oh!
-[ Laughing ] Okay. Yo.
-You are the greatest.
-You can keep the change.
-I can keep the change?
-Keep the change.
-From -- Come on.
Justin Willman.
-Wow.
-That is how you do it.
You can see Justin live
on his "Magic For Humans
In Person" tour.
Go to justinwillman.com
for tickets.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show."
-Yeah.
-Yo!